What Puigdemont wants is to gradually go building 1 state for the day
they want to have it their own And this is truly With this you can not
play with the things to eat you can not market And honestly I am very
concerned and and above all put in the hands of people who understand
about emigration something similar to voice I am concerned from 1
perspective even progressive because if the competencies
were requested by Vox all the time.
Mundo would tear his clothes but Puigdemont asks for them for the
same thing And that has nothing progressive about it That is
exactly reactionary but above all it does not seem constitutional to me.
Migration competence as at borders is strictly 1 sovereignty function that no
state can waive This cannot be resolved on
the fly in 1 corridor or by telephone.